that's a problem that every journalist
has to worry about i think in my case i
have a little bit of a luxury that other
journalists don't have which is that I'm
not covering the same people over and
over and over again if I want to I can
cover a story and move on to a
completely different topic afterwards
and never have to deal with any of those
people again so I can actually do that
scorch and burn thing where I descend on
a whole bunch of people and write
whatever I want about them and if it's
not flattering I don't ever have to talk
to them again that's not the situation
that some journalists are in if you're
covering the White House for the
Washington Post well you have to nurture
those relationships and and you can't
burn people all the time so I I'm
adventure a little bit more in the
direction of just saying what I think is
appropriate and letting the chips fall
where they may but at the same time you
have to be fair to your sources
otherwise no one will ever talk to you
if you get a reputation as somebody who
violates off-the-record privileges for
instance you know nobody's going to talk
to you so I work hard to be you know
honest with with my sources but you know
I don't I don't go out of my way to to
make them feel good either